cuz you had a bad day you're taking one
down but it's not always this bad and we
hope that this video will bring a smile
to your face stick around until the end
to see one of the most ironic but still
hilarious things ever don't forget to
give this video a thumbs up and
subscribe to the things now let's get to
the video this car owner okay this is
the stuff nightmares are made of
we have no idea what kind of speed bumps
this car went through but by the looks
of it it had to go through a serious
accident that ended up spilling the
paint absolutely everywhere how is that
even possible and more importantly how
are you supposed to get this paint off
the car we just hope that the person
inside ended up okay because this really
looks like a nightmare we don't ever
want to be a part of this girl have you
ever gone to the zoo and things didn't
go exactly as planned
no well Dudley Dursley and this little
girl definitely have a worse day than
you we have a feeling this kid's going
to be traumatized from her zoo
experience for the rest of her life we
feel you peacock sometimes we want to be
left alone
to this hungry person we can all agree
that vending machines are the worst but
they're especially bad when they don't
work how many times have you paid for
something but never got it no matter how
hard you shake the machine well luckily
for you you didn't do what this person
tried to do to get that first item out
because clearly that method doesn't work
on all vending machines shaking the
machine might actually help although by
the looks of it this vending machine
just gave up on life another car owner
okay just to warn you cars are going to
be super popular in our video so if
you're not a car owner you're
automatically having a better day than
most people but if you do own a car you
probably spilled a drink in it before
but this this looks like a complete mess
and we have no idea how a person's
supposed to clean it we just hope they
weren't on their way to work because
that's just a mess after a mess this mom
there are rare a few people that are
able to live a life without a phone and
since most of our batteries die down
pretty fast
we need to charge it but with so many
cords around things can get easily mixed
up like with this mom who clearly
thought she was charging her phone but
take a closer look
the actual plug she plugs it in the
headphones not the actual charger sorry
mom
it happens to the best of us this number
139 okay
imagine craving McDonald's ordering your
food and waiting in one of those fancy
new lines where you actually get a
number and your order gets called up we
have no idea what this person ordered
but seeing this on the screen must be
pretty frustrating considering there had
to have been number 139 somewhere hope
they ended up getting their food because
if not nothing says a ruined day as much
as having to engage with any kind of
customer service more than you're
supposed to this chef cooking is not
easy and mistakes happen in every single
kitchen no matter what you prepare
sometimes you might end up completely
destroying the dish no we mean the
actual dish as in the pot might
completely melt off for some reason we
have no idea what's happening here but
that must suck for whoever just wasted
all those potatoes and veggies kids
never buy cheap dishes and another car
owner still having a bad day here's a
bit of irony for you no one likes car
accidents and we really hope that this
person ended up being okay but here's a
lesson never predict what will happen to
you with the license plate look at this
cars plate numbers or in this case plate
letters it's true it actually did get
wrecked who knows maybe the car owner
really predicted this event this swimmer
not a fan of swimming we have a feeling
this dude wasn't either after he
severely underestimated the distance
between the thing he jumped off and the
actual swimming pool this one had to
hurt but we do hope he ended up being
okay we can imagine something like this
really would put you off swimming for a
while so if you never had an accident
like this you're already automatically
doing better than this guy sorry dude we
hope you didn't get hurt too badly this
person trying to get out of the house if
your country never gets any snow your
life is automatically a lot easier than
it is for most people like this person
who probably tried to get out of the
house but realize they were totally
snowed in can you see it the stove looks
like another door we can't even imagine
what it must have been like digging
through this to get out
although to be fair they probably just
stayed in and took a day off the guy
with interesting shoes we're sure this
happens
you before but if it didn't you better
knock on wood imagine getting up in the
morning in the dark because your partner
is still asleep something like this
could easily happen to you and you could
be wearing your partner's shoe without
even knowing we just want to know how
long it took for this guy to find out
and how many people actually noticed it
before him poor dude this unlucky loser
calling someone a loser is usually very
rude but in this case there's no better
word to describe a total opposite of
being a winner have any chance of
winning the lottery is very slim but why
the odds of having the numbers that are
all one number lower than the winning
numbers our heart dropped just from
looking at this we can't even imagine
how this person might have felt when
they saw those numbers this kitchen
owner having a properly fitted kitchen
is important but sometimes just
sometimes that just doesn't work out
imagine waking up in the morning going
to get some breakfast and walking into
this we're pretty sure we just go right
back to bed because that's just way too
much to handle
so trust us it's safe to say this person
is having a worse day than you but check
your kitchen just to make sure because
you never know when those cabinets will
start falling down this person and the
car we're telling you there are a lot of
cars in this video car owners really
don't have it easy
imagine forgetting to close your window
coming to your car in the morning and
finding it all snowed in from the inside
and outside is this a good enough excuse
to take a day off work it definitely
sounds like it because there's probably
nothing you could do until the snow just
melts off that poor car and this one too
seriously there's nothing worse than
something happening to your car cars are
expensive but this ridiculous accident
looks like it'd be pretty expensive to
fix just imagining opening your car door
and half the door ending up still
attached to the car how could this even
happen in the first place do you think
the person was just able to shut the
door and open it normally again we
definitely hope so because otherwise
that really looks like the person had
the worst day ever
this student if you never missed your
exam you automatically have a better day
than a lot of people sometimes it's hard
to track things and keep a calendar when
you're a student so imagine what this
kid
must've felt when they realized their
exam actually passed they thought it was
the next day we're pretty sure we'd get
a heart attack if he ever saw a message
like that without knowing about the
finals or Diego
we hope he managed to sort it out
eventually this Ford Fiesta flame owner
Ford Fiesta flame just has a cool name
but it can easily become something else
if one of the letter falls off imagine
driving around with a Ford Fiesta lame
that definitely doesn't sound anywhere
near as cool as the original we really
feel for this guy and we hope he wasn't
too bothered because driving around in
the car with the word lame isn't exactly
fun it's a minor thing but it still
means someone out there has had a worse
day than you these plane passengers most
people don't really enjoy flying on a
plane anyways
so imagine seeing this midair a part of
the airplane wings seem to have taken
off don't know about you but we probably
just closed down the shutters and avoid
looking at it for the rest of the flight
and pray that everything will turn out
fine because this definitely doesn't
look good we just hope this plane how to
safe landing and nothing else was wrong
but from the looks of it we definitely
don't want to be on there this stressed
person so this person bought a stress
relief lotion and were assuming they
were under a lot of stress and very
excited to use this after all everyone
deserves a bit of pampering so imagine
if this doesn't happen when you want it
to or if you buy an expensive pampering
lotion that ends up crashing on the
floor like this one we're pretty sure
cleaning that up it wasn't really
distressing at all this phone owner
we've probably shown you one example of
how people with this you have a worse
day than you but if you're still not
convinced this incident might imagine
going to the zoo and ending up walking
out with an alligator eating your phone
definitely doesn't sound like a fun trip
and we really feel for the person who
probably lost their phone after this and
we really hope the alligator didn't
actually eat it because that just means
problems for those new people too this
banana lover
nobody likes when their food is being
messed with so you're already having a
better day if you're not one of those
people who doesn't love a banana for
breakfast well we don't love a banana
that falls apart as soon as you take it
out of the bag and
less than making a banana bread this
person will probably have to waste a
whole lot of bananas replay this part of
the video back and see how many times
we've said the word banana the person
who found a snake while driving if
you've never had anything happen driving
in a car you're already better than this
person imagine driving and going to work
or somewhere and then seen an actual
snake coming out of the car while you're
driving it's what happened to this mom
who totally freaked out we just hope she
wasn't on a highway because that would
definitely cause a few accidents snakes
on a plane is scary but snakes in the
car is definitely scarier this tarmac
kid looks like this kid just wanting to
play on his scooter but they ended up in
a slightly sticky situation it looks
like this kid tripped over on their
scooter and fell into the tarmac we can
imagine that was probably a nightmare to
clean but what's even worse is that they
didn't pick up their bike this seems
like a lot of work for the kid and for
the person that has to lay the tarmac
all over again the person that just
wanted an apple an apple a day might
keep a doctor away but we don't think
this Apple would actually do that all
this person wanted was an apple but what
they got was one of the most dangerous
fruits ever after the Apple slicer
blades got stuck in the fruit luckily
you can clearly see them because
otherwise this could end up pretty bad
remember an apple a day keeps the doctor
away only if it doesn't include anything
crazy like razor blades this unfortunate
person still not convinced your day is
not actually that bad imagine seeing
this horrifying thing spiders are scary
but what's even scarier is not being
able to get rid of them because they're
standing on top of the bug repellant
spray just looking at that spider makes
this one - just nope our way out of
there and accept the fact this spider
will eventually become a house pet will
forever fear we really hope that spider
eventually got off the spray anyways we
hope this made you realize your day
actually wasn't as bad and brought a
smile to your face and that's all for
our video don't forget to subscribe to
the things and tell us how you felt
about this video thanks for watching see
you next time